[Music]
hey guys in this mkbhd video we're going
to be taking a look at episode 2 of
youtube tips and yes this episode is
about graphics so in this episode i'll
just be talking to you guys basically
and giving you guys a few uh imagery of
the following things that are pretty
important to youtube graphics so pardon
me if i look to the side which is where
my notes are you're going to want to
have a logo
a channel design or banner if you happen
to be a youtube partner a video banner
which is above your video your intro
which is actually a moving graphic and
as an added bonus you can also have a
watermark now i actually have been
changing around with my watermark a
little bit so i just kind of have like a
temporary watermark that you guys can
check out and leave feedback on but you
also might be interested in making all
these things
in the same sort of color scheme to make
it easier to remember so as you can
probably already tell all of my graphics
are in some sort of form of red black
and white
and the three colors combined happen to
be my favorite colors but those three
colors together are pretty important to
a consistent color scheme now how
exactly do you go about creating these
images well there are a number of ways
that you can try and a number of ways
that you can let other people try
my intro was created using a template
and using a tutorial from another
youtube user i don't even remember where
i got it but it took me a couple days to
actually put together and it's only five
seconds long if you want to hold an
intro contest to let other people who
are already watching your videos
actually try to make an intro for you
you can or use other people's tutorials
to do so with still graphics like your
channel design your video banner or your
watermark i really suggest getting
getting to know [ __ ] [ __ ] is one of my
favorite pieces of software it's free
it's an alternative to photoshop cs5 and
it's almost as powerful it's a very very
powerful piece of software so if you get
to know [ __ ] and i think you'll you'll
find that that's one of my favorite
pieces of software and could be one of
yours
you can make some really nice graphics
now my channel banner and background
were both made with photoshop however my
video banner my watermark and all the
other still graphics on my channel were
made with [ __ ] so that goes to show you
that it can be pretty powerful so
overall in my opinion it might not seem
like a big deal to you but i think that
when you're just starting out or when
you're actually building your brand it
can be a really good idea to establish a
really solid color scheme that people
can remember you by whether it's a blue
and white or red and black or some
orange and black or something crazy but
honestly it's up to you and you can i
like i suggested
try to get to use [ __ ] and watch some
[ __ ] tutorials there are some really
great users out there i'll probably try
to link a few up right here that can
help you out a lot with [ __ ] if you
message them or just watch their videos
so this has been mkbhd with quick
episode episode two of getting your
youtube videos together more
professionally and this has been on
graphics stay tuned for episode three
which should be coming up i'll probably
be making these videos once every week
or so maybe a week and a half or two
weeks they're kind of difficult to make
you'd be surprised either way see you
next time mkbhd signing out peace
[Music]